So a one way you can think
about comparisons between
Marxism and the utilitarian
tradition is that both have a
micro story and a macro story.
So when you think about
the utilitarian tradition,
we have the micro story of the
parade Oh principle and how in one,
each individual transaction,
uh,
we'll go and then we have a macro story
that if you allow people to transact
freely, you get the most efficient
utilitarian result of a time.
And so you get the rights utility
synthesis at least in the aspiration.
And other way of putting that is what
Adam Smith famously referred to as an
invisible hand theory that while no
individual participant is interested in
generating an efficient aggregate outcome,
indeed each individual participant
is just trying to get on his hind
indifference curve as possible.
The biproduct of their collective
individually selfish actions is this
beneficent, um, overall results.
And so that's the invisible hand of the
market that Smith talks about in the
wealth of nations.
Marks two has a micro story and macro
story and an invisible hand theory.
And that's why we're going
to spend today's lecture.
And next Monday's lecture.
Talking about today, principally, we're
going to focus on his micro story, uh,
his,
his story of how wealth gets created
at the micro level under capitalism.
And then we will link it,
um,
on Monday to his macro story.
And he to you will see,
has an invisible hand theory that is to
say the particular players at the micro
level confront incentives to
behave in certain ways. Um,
and the byproduct of their actions is,
is a macro result,
which nobody understands
or intense the differences.
We'll see that for Marx,
the invisible hand isn't
entirely benevolent.
It's Bella benevolent for a while,
but then it starts to become malevolent
over time because of the way that the
dynamics of capitalism
play themselves out.
So that's the sort of where
we're headed in the medium term.
In the next couple of lectures I want
though before heading into the micro story
to make a couple of conceptual points.
Um,
remember that when we
look at enlightenment,
thinkers were concerned first and
foremost with the fact that they are all
motivated by the idea of individual
freedom as the highest good and basing
politics on scientific principles.
Um,
rather than appeals to or natural law or
religion or tradition or anything else.
And I just want to highlight what Marx is,
assumptions about those two things are,
I've actually mentioned these in
one way or another in, in, uh,
last Monday's lecture.
But just to emphasize,
first of all,
the idea of freedom in Marx is captured
beautifully in this very famous passage,
um, that he wrote Ashley to
relatively young marks his,
his critique of The Hague aliens,
um,
in the and their followers Feuerbach
in a work called the German ideology.
He has this,
um,
very vivid description of what he means
by unfreedom the antithesis of he's his
ideal. He says the division of Labor,
which we talked about last time,
offers us the first example.
As long as man remains in natural society,
that is as long as a cleavage exists
between the particular and the common
interests as long. Therefore,
as activity is not voluntary,
not naturally divided.
Man's own deed becomes an alien.
Nepal are opposed to him which enslaves
him instead of being controlled by him.
For as soon as the division
of labor comes into being,
each man has a particular exclusive
sphere of activity which is forced,
done. Write this down. I'll put the slides
up. You can get them on the Internet.
So as soon as the division
of labor comes into being,
each ma ma man has a particular exclusive
sphere of activity which is forced
upon him and which he cannot
escape. He is a hunter, a fisherman,
a shepherd,
or a critical critic and he must remain.
So if he does not want to lose his
means of livelihood while in a communist
society,
this is his utopian ideal when nobody
has one exclusive sphere of activity,
but each can become a comp
accomplished in any branch.
He wishes society regulates the general
production and makes it possible for me
to do one thing today and
another tomorrow. This is baby,
the most famous line in all of
marks to hunt in the morning,
fish in the afternoon,
rear cattle in the evening and criticize
the after Dina just as I have a mind
without ever becoming a hunter,
a fisherman, a shepherd,
or a critic.
So this is a utopian marks,
this idea that as soon as
you have a division of labor,
we are no longer free.
We're in slave to our particular
place in the division of Labor.
Remember what I read to you from Adam
Smith's description of the pin factory.
You know, somebody spends their whole
life stretching that wire for the pin.
Somebody spends their whole life putting
the heads on the pin that that's a
sense which marks wants to say we're
alienated from our true selves once the
division of Labor sets in.
And we can only return to being a
fully rounded human beings at one with,
with ourselves when the,
when the division of Labor
ultimately is abolished.
And a precondition for that is the super
abundance of wealth that capitalism is
cat capitalism is historically
destined to create.
Um, and how we will finally
get there is the story.
Marx believed of how his macro
theory would play out over time.
And we will only reach a communist
society where people can be genuinely free
once the need for a division of Labor
has been obviated by the existence of a
superabundance of wealth.
So all of that's coming.
But this is just to underscore that is
basic ideal is freedom and not equality.
And his argument is going to be,
as I said to you last time,
that the condition for the
free development of each
is the free development of
all second,
just to come back to his and
underscore his theory of science.
Mark's is an objectivist.
He believes that there are um,
forces operating in history,
which he calls the materialist
conception of history,
which shape the way history on faults.
History has a direction.
It's moving through a variety of phases.
Each of which has internal contradictions.
And the way they play themselves out
is going to determine what happens.
So that tension in a feudal
society between the feudal,
between the peasants and the Lords is
gonna determine the way in which conflict
in that society, um, occurs.
Then you'll get the emergence of a
bourgeois class and they will create
capitalism.
But that will bring in bringing forth
a working class who will get into
conflicts with them.
And as those conflicts play out,
you'll eventually get
communism and socialism.
It's a reductionist theory.
As I said to you before,
think of Bill Clinton's line.
It's the economy stupid.
Most of what happens if not all of what
happens that's of any importance in
politics is determined
by economic interests.
Whether people understand this or not
or agree with it or not is beside the
point.
And that brings us to a third element
of this Marxian science that I just want
to underscore which will be
relevant for today's lecture,
is that Marx makes a distinction between
a class in itself and a class for
itself. And I want to spend
a couple of minutes on.
First is definition of class and then
this in itself for itself distinction.
A lot of people say that
Mark's is auntie individual.
He's not individualist because he thinks
about things in terms of classes and
clos conflict.
That is a very superficial
reading of Marx as um,
a very eminent scholar called Yawn.
Alster has pointed out in many books
that he's written on the subject.
Actually marks is an individualist
because if you look at how he defines
classes,
he defines them by reference to
the way in which the, the, the,
the way in which individuals
relate to the means of production.
So what is it that makes you work in
class as opposed to a member of the
capitalist laws?
What makes you working cause is if you
have to sell your labor power to somebody
else in order to live.
So if you want to know where the
somebody is working class, you say,
does he have to sell his labor power to
somebody else in order to live or not?
If the answer is yes, he's
working class, the answer is no,
he's not working class.
So you might say,
hmm, well I have, you know,
I ha I have to come in here and work
every day to get paid my salary.
I have to sell my labor to
the university in that sense,
but I don't, I'm not working class
you. You might think, you know,
somebody else might tell me I'm working
plus, but they can speak for themselves.
You know, I, I drive a nice
car. I live in the suburbs,
I'm not working class. Um, Mark's,
his answer is to appeal
to this distinction being
between a class in itself and
a class for itself.
The answer is Shapiro.
You had just diluted,
you might think you are not working class.
But that's because you don't understand
your objective position in the division
of Labor.
You are working class whether
you understand it or not.
And that's a class I'm working class in
a class in itself since I'm not working
class in the class for itself if I
don't believe that I'm working class.
So the in itself
represents the objective division
definition of plus the four itself is the
subjective okay.
Where the people actually believe that
working class and perceive themselves to
be working class. But what
matters for the, for the uh,
movement of history is the
in itself what's ultimately
going to drive everything
is the logic, the object of
logic, of class conflict,
not the subjective logic of what people
think is their position in the social
division of Labor. So, um,
it's important to keep those two things
separate. Now marks, as I've already said,
was a utopian thinker and
he does ultimately want to
say for reasons that that
I'll get into later today and
more and more depth on Monday.
He does ultimately want to say that what
differentiates a communist revolution
from all previous revolutions is that
these two things will become synonymous.
That for the first time in history,
the working class in four itself,
we'll come to see it self as
the working class in itself.
We will understand our objective position
in the division of labor and self
consciously create the new order.
Whereas in all previous
modes of production,
people don't really understand
their position and the
object of scheme of things
and so they create orders
as invisible hands.
To go back to Adam Smith's term,
they create orders as byproducts
of their intended activities,
not as products of their
intentional design.
And so that's, that's that distinction
between in itself and for itself.
Now you might listen to all of
this and you could say, wow,
yeah,
it's a kind of quaint 19th century idea,
but it doesn't have much to do with the
white people live in the world today.
After all,
as we have all noticed with
great intensity and the
past year and a half of the
financial crisis.
Many people who work for wages
yeah
also have money in the stock market.
Well,
but then they're capitalists aren't they?
Because stock is capital.
So you know,
I have my retirement money and my Tia
Cref has college professors get it in the
stock market. So I'm an owner
of capital as well as a worker.
And this sort of,
um,
binary distinction between the working
class and the capitalist class. Just it,
it just too simple minded.
What do you think Marx would say to that?
Anybody?
Any takers?
I'm not really working class because you
know, I've got, I've got money and I,
you know, I have stocks and
vested in all kinds of things.
Mutual funds,
no.
So I'm not really working for us any,
anyone think what marks might
say to that? Not, not easy.
I think that what he would
say is this, he'd say, well,
the definition of working class is that
you have to work for somebody else in
order to live. Not that you choose to
work for somebody else in order to lab.
So if I have enough money in my Tia craf
invested in the stock market that I can
quit tomorrow and do just fine,
then I'm not working class.
So it's, it's this element of
compulsion that makes you working five.
So it doesn't,
it's not important from Marxists point
of view that some of us might own stocks,
but if we really owned
enough stock that we would,
if we were not in this position of having
to work for somebody else in order to
live,
we wouldn't be working class.
And so people could move in and
out of the working class. Indeed.
I know people on the Yale Faculty who
two years ago we're about to retire and
live off their accumulated Tia craf
and then it went up in smoke when,
uh, when the wheels came off the
economy and now they're not retiring.
So what Marx would say,
where's while they managed to get
out of the working class in theory in
principle, but then they fell back
down into the working class. So it's,
it's this element of compulsion.
They're not retiring because they don't
have enough and therefore they have to
work for somebody else in order to live.
So that's the distinction between a
class in itself and a class for itself
that drives his theory.
Okay. So what is the theory?
Okay,
we're back to lock those of you who
read chapter five of the second treaties
carefully.
When we looked at Locke and his
theory of property saw how for Locke,
the workmanship ideal plays out in the
economic realm with the proposition that
most of the value of our
product comes from work.
Very crude in lock. At one
point he says, you know,
90% of it comes from work.
The rest is natural resources.
At another point he says
99% of it comes from work.
The rest is natural resources.
Um,
but he locked doesn't really have any
mechanism by which labor supposedly
creates value.
And in the 17th and 18th century,
there were really three theories
floating around. There were,
as I think I mentioned to you on
Monday, there were in, in Europe,
particularly France, the physiocrats
who said value comes from the land,
but there were English theorist
who looked at them and said, no,
that can't be right because look how rich
hollandaise and they don't have a lot
of land.
And so they thought value came from trade.
But then the third group starting
in the 17th century with Hobbes,
so William Petty Locke and others said,
no value comes from work.
That source of value is work.
And that's what Mark's picks up on in
trying to develop a theory of value.
And his theory is more refined than locks,
more fine than smiths and
more refined than Ricardo's.
It starts with this idea of socially
necessary labor time or smelled,
and he'd defines smelt as the labor
time required to produce any use value.
Remember what anyone remind us,
what is a use value?
Monday's lecture. What's a yes? Yes.
Is it useful? Right? So anything
with utility is a use value,
right?
So it's the amount of labor time required
to produce any use value under the
conditions of production.
Normal for a given society and with the
average degree of skill and intensity of
the labor prevalent in the society.
So let's suppose
lay on it and I are making typewriters.
Yeah.
One of the big sort of conundrums
of labor theories of value had been,
well what if,
what if Lillian is a perfectionist
and he spends twice as long making his
typewriter as I spend
making my typewriter.
But
you know,
most of the perfectionisms action his
own head because at the end of the day
they're the same.
MMM.
Marx would say he wouldn't,
he would not say lay on his typewriter
was worth twice Shapiro's type by it
because he put twice as
much labor into it. No,
because half of his Labor
would be socially unnecessary.
So it's,
it's socially necessary labor time or
if a new labor saving device was created
so that the keys could be
made much more quickly,
then we are laborious doing it with
file and I use the new machine,
the labor saving device
and lay on it doesn't.
So my type artists get
produced more quickly.
His type art not going to sell for
more than my typewriter because again,
he's using socially unnecessary labor.
So that's the notion of the
average degree of skill,
intensity of labor prevalent
in the society at the time. So,
um,
that's what's going to determine the
value of commodities. The long term,
remember we talked about the,
the natural value,
the long term equilibrium price of a
commodity is going to be determined by the
amount of labor power that is
socially necessary to produce it.
And this idea of socially
necessary includes everybody
working at the same or an
average intensity.
And it includes using available
technologies because if
some use them and others
don't,
those who don't are going to be um,
deploying unnecessary labor time.
And that's not going to be reflected in
the value of the product because in a
competitive market,
the most cheaply priced
commodity is going to beat.
The other sound important to remember,
Mark's works for the model of a
perfectly competitive economy,
okay?
Right? In which equivalence exchange
for equivalent, no cheating.
I mentioned that on
Monday, okay. A perfectly,
his model is a perfectly competitive
economy. At least at the beginning.
He's got a view about how economies evolve
over time to become uncompetitive and
we'll get to that.
But initially,
and then his analytic story
in a competitive economy,
the most cheaply produced products are
going to drive out the last cheaply
produced.
And so it's socially necessary labor time,
not average, not actual.
Doesn't matter how much blood,
sweat and tears Leon aid actually uses.
Um,
what counts is how much he knew
he, she needs to use. Okay?
So that you could say, okay, but,
but that's not the beginning
of the whole story.
And to get into that,
we have to go a step further with marks
and look not just at the labor theory of
value,
but the labor theory of surplus value.
This is where the rubber
meets the road for marks.
What he wants to say is
living human labor power
is the only source of fresh value.
I've exchanged value.
So this is the workmanship,
IDL on crack. Okay.
Living Human Labor power is
the only source of fresh value.
So when Locke said, you
know, work is 90%, uh,
or maybe it's 99% of the value of
commodities and the rest commerce from the
common locks,
um,
Mark's just going to say it's
100% all exchange value comes work
and why he's thinking of here,
it's two things.
One is he wants to say,
if you, if you look at all the
commodities that are produced in an,
in a market economy,
the one thing they all have in common
is that that products of human work.
Yeah.
It's the,
it's the single common denominator,
right?
Yeah.
It is. The capacity to work
is a commodity like any other,
so that we'll, we'll get into
this in more detail in a minute.
But when you think about what
it is that people are paid,
what is it that a worker is paid?
It's determined like the
value of any other commodity.
So when we say what is
the value of a buck,
it's determined by the amount of labor
power necessary to produce that book.
And when we say what is
the value of a steelworker,
it's determined by the amount of
labor power necessary to produce that
steelworker.
The workers are commodity and justice.
Same sense as the book is a commodity.
So wages are determined by the
costs of producing the worker.
And
the reason a physicist gets paid more
than a manual labor, then it's simple.
It costs more to produce the physicist,
then it could cost to
produce the manual labor.
All the training and education and so
on that goes into their physicists costs
more than the training and education
that goes into the producing a manual
labor.
So wages are not explained by the
value of what the workup produces.
This is one of the things
people often get wrong.
Values I explained by the
cost of producing the worker.
I'll say that again.
It's important.
Wager is wages are explained not by
the value of what the workup produces,
but rare that by the cost
of producing the worker.
So why do you think of that?
Why would somebody say
somebody who thought this is,
what would mark say about,
why is that Michelangelo
Painting Worth so much?
Well, why does it, why does
a professional baseball get
tens of millions, maybe hundreds of
millions of dollars if this is true?
Anyone think about,
I think of what Marx would say.
Okay.
Anyone want to guess?
Yeah.
What do you say?
It's because like how much time they
had to practice and how much, uh,
like money and time they put
into learning their skills.
That would be part of
it. But still, you know,
I mean there are only
so many hours in a day.
How do you get up to $100 million salary?
Uh,
it's, it's uh, I mean,
you're on the right track.
Any, what else goes into the creation
of a major league baseball player?
Why don't they have very good major
league baseball players and Brit,
okay,
it's,
they don't have minor leagues.
They don't have farm teams that there's
huge costs associated with getting the
one brilliant best of all time player.
So that's what he would have to say.
Or if you think about the value,
the value of a Michelangelo painting,
it's not just the
training of Michelangelo,
it's all those failed painters that
all those popes wasted all that money
investing in.
But that all goes in in some
indirect sense into the,
um,
into the wage differential.
So that's sort of what it's of course,
if it is a stretch.
And one thing that marks
did not think about, mmm,
was what we call in in economics today,
winner take all markets. Anyone know
what a winner take all market is?
Once a winner take all market,
what is, what does the
phrase suggest to you? What,
what do you think a winner
take all market should be?
Think about the wage differential between
the major leagues and Minor League
Baseball is huge, right? That's
a winner take all market.
The way you can think about it is,
um,
before the advent of the gramophone
record being a really pretty good opera
singer could, um,
you could have, you'd do pretty
well. Every major city would have,
you know, an opera with a pretty good
opera singer. I'd make a good living.
Why don't you have the gramophone record?
Then everybody can buy Pavarotti,
right?
So then whether or not the
d the difference between
Pavarotti and the next best
and third best opera singer,
um,
becomes much more important. So that's
the idea of a winner take all market. Um,
and,
and Mark's had nothing to say about them,
so he would have to reach for this
rather contorted logic of saying it.
It just costs much more to produce,
um,
the best baseball player in the world.
Um,
because you have to run everything that
goes into that production, not his own,
not only his own practicing and training,
but everything that goes with it.
So that's the first point.
Labor power is a commodity
and it's exchange value,
which price is determined by
what it costs to produce it.
But then this is the magic.
This is the workmanship ideal on crack.
This is the idea.
He wants to say that
living human labor power is
a unique commodity in that
it's consumption as a use
value leads to the creation of fresh
exchange value. What does this mean?
It means that suppose I have some money
and I spend,
you know,
$1,000 on a wonderful meal,
good wine,
okay.
At the end of that meal, you
know I, it's gone, right?
The thought I paid the check
and it's gone, I've consumed it.
Whereas if I had spent that
thousand dollars hiring one
of you to paint one wall
in my home,
when it's done,
my home's worth something more
because it has freshly painted wall.
That's what he means.
Okay?
So that living human labor power differs
from other commodities in that W it's
consumption as a use value leads to
the creation of fresh exchange value,
right? You eat the meal, it's gone,
but you consume the labor power of the
person painting your house or the person
working in your factory and it's not gone
right in it.
I mean the labor power gone in
the sense that it's been expanded,
those calories have been spent,
but you have something in a greater value.
I have a house that's worth more than
it was before you hired that person to
paint it.
And that's what makes Labor power unique,
right?
And it is.
He wants to say it is the
only source of fresh value.
Okay.
So a couple of just terms here to
get straight his archaic language,
you probably read,
he makes a distinction between what
he calls constant capital and variable
capital,
all of that or what oil you
need to think about. There is,
um, capital is what the capitalist
spends in the productive process.
Variable capital is wages
and constant capitalist.
Everything else,
sometimes he uses these symbols.
C means all capital.
Big C means all capital.
Little c means everything the capitalist
spends on things other than wages and V
is spent on wages and why
he might call it variable.
So the idea is that wages are
always driven toward subsistence.
This is, uh, an empirical assumption.
Mark's makes a few empirical assumptions
of all the empirical assumptions he
makes. This is the one that
actually is the most accurate.
He wants to say that there are always
some unemployed in capitalist economies
and because there are always some
unemployed in capitalist economies,
wages will be driven towards subsistence.
Because if you have,
say a union that organizes
and drives up wages,
the employer will then go and
hire nonunion workers and say,
well, will you work for me at subs at
something lower than the union wage?
And the answer will be yes because the
unemployed worker won't have a choice.
Okay, so wages of B will be
driven towards subsistence.
Now that puts on the table another
question. Well, what is subsistence?
Okay,
what is subsistence?
And and Mark's does say,
well it has a social and historical
element. So that is to say,
you know,
in a society like ours,
the definition of subsistence
might include having enough
money to buy a car in
order to drive to work.
Whereas obviously that was not
true in 19th century Britain.
So what counts as subsistence changes?
And we will see there
are other features of,
of Marx's theory of capitalism which show
that this actually an belt impetus for
the what's constant subsistence to go up.
But at any given time,
the accepted level of subsistence and
wages will be driven toward that because
of the existence of what he flamboyantly
described as the reserve army of the
unemployed.
Right.
That's what keeps wages at subsistence
or close to it in a competitive economy.
Okay.
Yeah.
Let's do a little micro transaction.
Suppose there's a working day.
Okay.
And suppose the ex the accepted
working days, 10 hours long,
mark says, well think about what the
worker is doing. The work as you know,
is producing cotton.
Let's say it doesn't really matter what.
And for some portion of that working day,
the cotton that is producing
wine eventually sold is
going to cover the cost of
his wages.
So the workup produces
cotton all day long. But the,
and the capitalist eventually sells the
cotton right and get something for it.
And then he's gotta pay.
His worker is wage.
And we're just going to say for
the purposes of this example, the,
the work that's done in the first four
hours is going to cover the wage bill.
And the rest is,
is what Marx calls surplus.
So that's the difference between
necessary and surplus labor time.
And Mark's has the eye,
do you have a rate of exploitation,
which is the ratio of national,
sorry, day surplus labor time.
You could even make an little index.
And so you'd say it's 1.5.
Okay. So this is the capitalists, the,
the value that's produced that covers the
wage bell. This is the wreck. Of course,
this is an all profit,
right?
Why isn't it profit? Why isn't
all of that profit? Somebody
think about it. You're a capitalist. Yeah.
Cause somebody goes to the actual,
I guess building where they're working
or other, um, or even material needed to
exactly. The Kappa Sas to buy raw
material. It's to do advertising,
has to run as to have a
system of managers, um,
uh, you know, research and development.
All of that has to be paid out of this.
So profit is, you know, some subset of
this, but it's not all of this. Okay.
So,
okay,
so we're in the cotton business
and it's a competitive business.
And so another cotton manufacturer says,
you know what?
I think these work is a slacking.
I'm an essay from now on to my workers.
You work 11 hours.
Yeah,
wages are ready at subsistence
by assumption, right?
So you know,
the workers might no or not,
and they say it can say goodbye, I'll
get somebody's unemployed to do it then.
Okay.
So,
okay,
if you do that,
we now have an 11 hour working day.
The rate of exploitation goes up,
right?
Because now there's seven hours of
surplus labor rather than six hours of
surplus labor. You now
you might say, well,
the workers going to get worn out
sooner and die, uh, sooner. We'll edge.
That's just suspend
disbelief about that and say,
in fact, so this, this capitalist is
going to do better than this capitalist.
So this capital is going to be able to
sell his or her product more cheaply and
therefore this capital is
going to be in trouble.
Paypal. Thank you know,
Marxism capitalists are
afraid of the working class.
No. On Marcia's theory, who
is a capitalist if radar,
who is the capitalists looking
over his shoulder rock?
Yeah, the capitalist down the street.
Not, they couldn't care less about.
It's not worried about the workers.
He's worried about the capitalists who
can come into his industry and produce
more effectively.
Okay.
So if you can,
if you can make these workers work
an extra hour, you're going to do it
and then everybody else is
going to have to do it, right?
Or they're going to go on our business.
And this is why Mark's wants to say
this is what he calls an increase in
absolute,
a surplus value.
This is why mark says under
primitive capitalism now,
early stages of capitalism,
the battles are going to be over things
like the length of the working day.
If any of you have done 19th
century British history,
you will know that one of
the big battles started.
This starts with the charters and the
early 19th century. Uh, and goes on.
What are they pushing for the 10 hours
bell? They want the 10 hours bill.
They want parliament to come
in and say working days,
10 hours to limit this.
So to the extent that the workers can
organize politically and put pressure to
get a 10 hours bell, then
you, you, you limit this.
But in any case, Mark's
wants to say, you know,
there are only so many hours in a day
and people do have to sleep after all,
so you're not going to get much,
much out of this.
The real secret to capitalism's dynamism,
it's not the move from a to B,
it's the move from a to c.
Notice here we're back at a 10 hours
a day,
but now by assumption I'm saying
the capitalist is going to cover his
wage bell for that worker in three hours.
We had an for.
How's it going to do that?
Yeah,
pardon?
But you can't reduce wages because
wages are already at subsistence.
So you're going to have to buy assumption.
You, you have to produce the same,
you have to pay the same wages.
So how are you going to do it?
Technology. Exactly. The name
of the game is technology.
Somebody's going to go and buy a
spinning Jenny and put it in his factory,
and then the workers will
work way more productively.
And as a result of that,
the capitalists will cover
his wage bill more quickly.
Okay.
And of course the minute one
capitalist puts the spinning Jenny in,
everybody has to put the
Spinning Jenny yet, right?
Or else they're to go out of business
because the capitalists that's covering
his wage,
Bellin,
three hours of that work
as work rather than four.
It's going to be able to sell a cotton
more cheaply in the market and therefore
out outcompete the capitalist who
still still using the old system.
And so the way capitalism works is
that there's constant pressure for
technological innovation because the,
this is not a very effective way
of increasing productivity, right?
You can,
in the early stages,
you'll see that by the old there'll
be political limits, 10 hours bill,
there'll be natural limits,
human capacity.
So then all the pressure
is on dynamic innovation.
Okay?
Now,
okay,
this is where it gets interesting
because what he wants to say is, but
we know that only living human labor
power producer's surplus value.
So as, as you become more
and more capital intensive,
the capitalist is spending more and more
on the constant capital unless a nice
on variable capital to put it in modern
jargon production is becoming more
capital intensive.
You spending more and more of your,
of your investment
on
something that does
not produced new value.
So another way you can think
about this, um, and this,
remember I said to you last time,
all the classical political economists
thought they had to explain the declining
tendency and the rate of
what Mark's wants to say is,
okay,
if this is the status quo,
okay?
And one capitalist in the cotton industry
puts in the spinning Jenny and this
becomes the status quo.
This capitalist will have higher
profits than this capitalist, right?
But once they've all put
in the spinning Jenny,
the rate of profit in the cotton industry
will be lower than it was up here.
Okay, so there's a, there's a short run,
long run conflict of interest for
capitalist because in the short run at the
margin I will innovate
and my profits will go up,
but then everybody will copy me and the,
the rate of profit in the cop caught
an industry will fall over time.
Now there's,
that's us,
there's some dubious assumptions in that
which I'm going to come back to, um,
on Monday.
But I first want to just
draw your attention to some
of the normative aspects of
this.
What Marx calls the rate of exploitation,
as I said, is the ratio of
surplus to necessary labor time.
But now look down the
right hand side here.
What these got all this
is con this jargon,
but you can unpack it here.
Sov is the rate of exploitation and
it's all these things are basically
equivalent ratio. But look down
here and now think about this.
Suppose I was a capitalist and
you were a worker working for me.
Okay?
And suppose I said Time's a
tough in the cotton industry,
you've got a choice.
We can go to here or we can go to here.
We can pick B, uh, we can pick C,
but a is no longer an option.
A means I'm moving to Mexico can,
can't do a anymore.
So take your pick B or c. How many are
you going to take? Pick B. Hands up.
How many gonna Pick C. Okay, everybody.
But then it seems like this is
very counterintuitive, doesn't it?
Because
mm.
You all went for something that
according to Marx has a higher rate of
exploitation.
2.33 as opposed to 1.75.
Okay.
How can that be? How can
that make any sense? Okay.
And I'm just gonna tell you,
I'm going to go two minutes over here
to leave you with this to think about,
and then we'll pick up with it on Monday.
This is the,
there's a, but if you, if
you think about how people,
how people think about
how well off they are,
the parade oh system says,
am I m I on a higher or lower
indifference curve than I was on before?
It's a bit like when Ronald Reagan was
running for lead reelection in 1984.
His slogan was, are you better off than
you war? Who were four years ago? Right?
You look at your situation and you say,
what was my situation? Is it better?
Is it worse? Self referential
comparison. Mark says,
no,
that's not the relevant comparison.
The relevant comparison
is other referential.
You decide how well off you are,
not just by reference to what you get
compared to with what you got before,
but what by reference to
what others are getting.
So that in this kind of situation if
you say which is worse for the worker,
they may well say that a situation in
which they have more is worse than a
situation then which they have less
if the capitalist has even more
so. Mark's wants to say we're
inherently other referential.
What are we going to make
us more or less happy?
It's not just what we have but
what we have in relation to others.
So now, and it turns out on
this matter, he was half right.
Okay.
He was half right.
We see from huge number a hundred
years of studies of of sociology.
What people find acceptable and desirable
is connected to what others have.
But usually it's connected.
And this is where he was half wrong.
It's usually collected to what people
who are similarly situated to themselves
have.
So work is in the steel industry,
will compare themselves to
work as in the auto industry,
but work is in the auto industry while
not compare themselves to what executives
in the auto industry yet.
So people are other referential
but in a more horizontal sense.
And this is true up and
down the occupational scale.
So if you have been an it
and yell administrator,
one thing you will learn is it will
matter much more to a professor.
If he or she learns he's being paid
$2,000 less than the professor down the
corridor.
Then if he or she learns his pain,
he or she is being paid $200,000 less
than the attorney who lives next door to
them.
People compare themselves to others,
but they compare themselves
to similarly others.
Why that is
is uh,
immensely complicated
and interesting subject,
but it means that Marx was right to
think we're basically other referential.
We don't just ask the question,
has my utility who have gone up or down?
We do. We do compare ourselves
to others, but he was,
he was mistaken in thinking that
we would compare that work has,
would compare themselves to capitalists
rather than to other workers in deciding
whether or not they were well off,
and that would feed into his assumptions
about the conditions under which
workers would be likely
to become militant. Okay.
We'll start with that issue on Monday.